it just goes straight into your soul and
it takes you to the psychological prison
that you hold yourself in so it's your
own version of hell and i was definitely
there
talk about a strange trip it's
mind-blowing
megan fox gets candid about drinking
ayahuasca with machine gun kelly in
costa rica
it's hard to top that one man the till
death actress appeared on monday's jimmy
kimmel live with guest host arsenio hall
and opened up about her quasi spiritual
journey in the central american
wilderness
with her boyfriend after drinking the
psychoactive tea
used in ceremonial rituals as a
spiritual medicine
which btw induces auditory
and visual hallucinations do you guys
know what ayahuasca is
oh yes so we went to we went to costa
rica to do hiawaska like in a proper
setting like with indigenous people and
i was thinking it was like glamping or
something like that still gonna be like
a
some kind of five-star experience and
you get there and you really are in the
middle of the jungle and
you don't get to eat after like 1 p.m
you have to walk
a very far distance to get your water
you can't shower because they're in a
drought
nothing glamorous about it it's all a
part of sort of making you vulnerable
so that you surrender to the experience
megan recounted how the whole ceremony
kicked off by having
everyone in the group of 20 strangers
empty the contents of their stomachs
you all line up at like the edge of the
rain forest over this
weird fence and you go three by three
and you drink lemongrass tea until you
like by not your own volition just vomit
everything out of your body so you so
you have to vomit there's no way around
that get out of it and you have to open
a certain amount before they let you
get back with everybody so you're like
cheering on everyone as they like throw
up
yeah so megan admitted that she and mgk
had some reservations about throwing up
in front of strangers at first
but added that it's quote such a good
bonding experience
and it strips you of any vanity people
love it
and when it came to the ceremony itself
megan said the experience lasted three
nights and was quote
incredibly intense everybody's journey
is different the second night i went to
hell for eternity
um yeah and to just knowing eternity
is um like torture in itself because
there was no beginning middle or end so
you have like a real ego death
and megan says that ayahuasca was able
to help her in ways that therapy and
hypnotherapy
couldn't before it just goes straight
into your soul
and it takes you to the psychological
prison that you hold yourself in so it's
your own version of hell and i was
definitely there
while megan and machine gun kelly's
spiritual trip was private
they certainly haven't been shy about
showcasing their love in public
sharing steamy smooches at high profile
events
and gushing over each other on social
media
i think it's wonderful a source told et
in june that the two are quote
pretty inseparable at this point and are
already planning their future together
quote as far as engagement goes it is
likely that this will happen
sooner than later and it has been a
topic of conversation
without question and when it caught up
with megan last month to chat about her
new movie
till death a flick about a woman who
wakes up handcuffed to her dead husband
after a romantic evening at their
secluded lake house the actress revealed
what her man
thought of her edgy role he's an actor
as well and an artist so he likes to see
the different facets of what what i can
do for work and like
how i can push myself or be someone that
i'm
actually not and how good i can
hopefully be be at accomplishing that
and selling that
and in 2020 megan gushed to et over what
a talented actor mgk is while promoting
midnight in the switchgrass
the flake they co-star in that also
first sparked their real-life romance
i don't know if people understand what a
good actor he is he's so charismatic
he's so naturally gifted which is
annoying because he's also
a brilliant creative genius as a
musician
so then for him to show up on set and
just be so much better than you at what
you do for a living
is really annoying how do you see past
it being annoying then what drew you to
it instead of made you hate it
the tall blonde gorgeous supermodel